[Musique]
bon là les chiffres derrière c'est pas
bon non vu sous cet angle c'est pas bon
du tout même alors on vous rassure on
n'est pas venu là aujourd'hui pour vous
faire peur non au contraire on est venu
vous annoncer une bonne nouvelle
cette bonne nouvelle c'est que nous
avons la solution
- christophe caye chef d'entreprise
depuis 30 ans et moi maxime ducoulombier
porteur d'un projet de l'économie
circulaire depuis deux ans et vous vous
tous nous sommes la solution avec maxime
nous coopérons dans le cadre d'un
mouvement de chefs d'entreprises
engagées pour la planète un programme de
mécénat de compétences qui fait des airs
des centaines de chefs d'entreprise
comme moi et des centaines de porteurs
de projets environnementaux comme moi un
concept qui repose en ce qui me concerne
sur le partage de mes compétences
entrepreneuriales avec maxime et je
partage avec christophe mon expertise
sur les questions environnementales et
de gouvernance inclusive dans ce
mouvement il ya une multitude de projets
venant d'horizons très variés et de
toutes tailles qui nous ont rejoints et
l'enjeu c'est l'accélération de la
transition écologique de nos entreprises
alors concrètement on se voit à peu près
une fois par mois avec maxime et je
l'aide à challenge et son modèle
économique
ses objectifs son organisation encore sa
stratégie alors là christophe est sympa
franchement je partais dans tous les
sens forcément mon projet c'est de faire
interagir les acteurs du monde du déchet
avec ceux du circuits courts
alimentaires en mutualisant des moyens
de cyclos logistique pour créer des
boucles d'économie circulaire zéro
déchet zéro carbone zéro gaspillage
alors c'est vrai c'est un peu compliqué
mais le projet de maxime a un vrai
potentiel d'impact et c'est ça qui est
particulièrement inspirant grâce à
christophe j'ai enfin réussi
y à construire la structure juridique de
mon projet alors que c'était un vrai
point de blocage
de mon côté je l'aide à intégrer la
dimension inclusive au coeur de son
organisation alors moi j'ai tendance à l
habitude de collaborer mais maxime lui
m'apprend à coopérer vous faites
imed à mieux coopérer justement avec des
gens par exemple de l'économie sociale
et solidaire du monde de l'association
ou des collectivités ou des pouvoirs
publics et d'ailleurs il m'a déjà aidé à
interagir mieux avec un certain nombre
d'entre eux
finalement à travers le mouvement
entrepreneurs pour la planète
ensemble nous contribuerons à accroître
l'impact sociétal de nos deux
entreprises
et je peux vous assurer que pour un chef
d'entreprise c'est une vraie bouffée
d'oxygène qui ouvre sur le monde de
demain
et moi ça me permet clairement de lever
la tête du guidon
alors nous sommes déjà nombreux à nous
rejoindre dans ce mouvement
entrepreneurs pour la planète
ils sont issus d'univers différents
c'est une très belle diversité c'est ça
qui est très riche
par exemple on collabore avec le
président en france du numéro un mondial
des data center qui coopèrent avec le
directeur du parc national des calanques
et ensemble ils développent une solution
de compensation carbone en milieu marin
on peut penser aussi à cette spécialiste
de l'immobilier d'entreprise qui aide le
directeur d'un institut de recherche à
développer une gamme de vins en
agroécologie et dont les bénéfices
permettront de financer un programme de
protection de la biodiversité ou encore
ce dirigeant d'une société d'ingénierie
industrielle qui coopèrent avec une
start up pour développer à grande
échelle des potagers urbains connectés
et intelligent donc on n'est pas là
juste pour venir vous dire il faudrait
remplacer des gobelets en plastique par
des mugs mettre à disposition des
parkings à vélos collaborateurs on parle
bien de remplacer les énergies fossiles
du
processus de production de bio sourcés
les matières premières de raccourcir les
chaînes logistiques déco concevoir des
produits et services de transformer des
déchets en ressources
on parle d'un pacte massif et direct en
fait ce qu'on est venu vous dire c'est
qu'on a changé d'ère nous sommes entrés
dans une nouvelle ère une ère où les
dirigeants d'entreprises considèrent que
la protection de l'environnement fait
partie de leur responsabilité et de
celle de leur organisation
une ère où les dirigeants d'entreprises
et leurs sociétés vont devenir le bras
armé de la transition écologique et nous
y sommes déjà
les entreprises nos entreprises vos
entreprises vont devenir le bras armé de
la transition écologique
alors ça peut paraître étrange mais
quand on y regarde de plus près cela
devient une évidence aucun vous l'auriez
oublié ce sont nos entreprises qui
conçoivent qui développe qui produisent
qui distribue et qui recycle les
produits et services que nous consommons
au quotidien en fait elles sont
incontournables pour produire et vendre
des voitures électriques
je préfère des vélos des smartphones
éco-conçus je préfère des livres en
papier recyclé des avions à hydrogène
d'être un néon si on peut penser à des
corps-morts de forme biomimétique à des
batteries 100% carbone du power passe
c'est une sorte de pâte à modeler garder
d'hydrogène des micros méthaniseur la
semaine dernière j'ai acheté une
combinaison de surf il n'y avait pas de
néoprène c'était des coquilles d'huîtres
et les canards en plastique
je crois qu'ils ont compris gré en fait
on est de plus en plus nombreux à penser
que l'on n'arrivera pas protéger
l'environnement
uniquement en réduisant notre
consommation les seuils et on n'y arrive
pas
ça ne marche pas la preuve si on vous
demande maintenant de nous donner vos
clés de voiture beau smartphone vos
vêtements y aurait personne et c'est
normal c'est humain
on a tous du mal à se débarrasser de
notre confort matériel
je dois avouer moi le premier en fait on
peut toujours rêver de changer le monde
sans les entreprises mais à priori c'est
pas gagné ça va prendre du temps
beaucoup trop de temps et du temps quand
on parle de transition écologique on en
manque
alors pour ceux qui me connaissent le
savent je suis pas vraiment du genre
patient toute façon les membres du giec
le groupe d'experts internationaux pour
le climat nous le disent
on a dix ans pour changer les choses
transformer le modèle et sauver notre
planète est notée avec mais alors la
bonne nouvelle c'est que dix ans fait en
gros le temps qu'il faut pour
transformer en profondeur une entreprise
deux exemples c'est le temps qu'il a
fallu pour que l'un des plus grands
énergéticiens allemands passent au 100%
renouvelable et c'est le temps qu'il a
fallu pour qu'émerge le numéro un
mondial du covoiturage
mais sauf que dix ans et maintenant
c'est maintenant qu'on s'y met mais par
contre attention pas sous la contrainte
personnellement moi je n'avance pas sous
la contrainte alors que je bouillonne
d'énergie quand j'allais faire des
choses ça je le confirme il bouillonne
mais vous savez quoi ce principe de la
contrainte
il est valable aussi pour le monde de
l'entreprise ces deux entreprises
décident par elle même de concevoir des
produits des services éco responsable
elles le feront plus vite et mieux que
sous la contrainte
en fait si on veut aider nos entreprises
à agir vite
arrêtons de les considérer comme le
problème il faut avoir une approche
positive et inclusive
nous devons coopérer avec les chefs
d'entreprise et leurs sociétés plutôt
que les dénoncer nous devons les
accompagner
d'autant que les contraindre nous devons
les soutenir
plutôt que les sanctionner maintenant de
toute façon nos entreprises nos
entreprises elles n'ont pas le choix
elles doivent se transformer d'abord les
entreprises qui ne vont pas prendre le
virage de la transition écologique vont
avoir du mal à recruter et en
particulier les jeunes générations comme
moi c'est un peu plus jeunes ensuite
elles vont avoir de plus en plus de mal
à trouver les bons partenaires en
particulier les partenaires financiers
qui se détournent de plus en plus des
projets paulo et privilégie les projets
verts sur mes projets par exemple la bpi
la banque publique d'investissement nous
prête à taux zéro et l'ademe nous
finance jusqu'à 70% la flotte de nos
vélos électriques
oui mais surtout l'investissement dit
esg environnementales sociales et de
gouvernance représente déjà plus de 25 %
des investissements dans le monde sait
qu'un début ça progresse très vite et ça
va devenir la norme
la semaine dernière je discutais qu'un
des amis qui est banquier d'affaires
dans le hall and gas et justement il me
disait je n'arrive plus à financer mes
projets c'est devenu infernal
à tel point que l'art vous savez quoi en
ce moment il est en train de suivre une
formation à polytechnique pour passer
dans les énergies renouvelables
finalement lui aussi s'est recyclé en
fait la g m'adresser les amis chefs
d'entreprise si vous n'avez pas les bons
collaborateurs
si vous n'avez pas les bons partenaires
vous n'aurez pas les bons produits
vous allez perdre vos clients cqfd
nos entreprises vont disparaître
l'extinction masse des dinosaures en
fait en aidant nos entreprises à se
transformer nous les aidons à assurer
leur pérennité et agir plus vite pour la
planète
là j'entends déjà les potes qui vont
dire oui maxime se sympa vous êtes
mignon mais c'est utopique tout ça et
c'est vrai que moi le premier je pensais
bien que j'aurais tant de g et sous le
soleil du réchauffement climatique avant
que toutes les entreprises ne bouge
ouais sauf qu'un certain victor hugo
disait les utopies d'aujourd'hui sont
une réalité de demain et christophe
je crois que tu es bien placé pour le
savoir alors c'est vrai j'ai eu la
chance de créer il ya plus de dix ans
une entreprise dans le domaine des
énergies renouvelables avec l' envie de
partager avec d'autres et de participer
surtout avec d'autres à l'émergence
d'une solution alternative aux énergies
fossiles et nucléaires à l'époque quand
je présentais mon activité
la plupart de mes interlocuteurs me
disais dans le solaire saga jesse ça
marchera jamais ton truc faut avouer que
l'électricité solaire coûtait 10 fois
plus cher que les autres énergies
et vous savez quoi aujourd'hui
l'électricité solaire est devenu
l'électricité la plus compétitive du
monde
en fait mon utopie de l'époque est
devenu notre réalité d'aujourd'hui
et là je crois christophe qu'ils sont
prêts pour qu'on leur parle de l'effet
de bascule
vas-y cette conclusion alors les fêtes
bascule
c'est un principe qui est basé sur les
travaux de rodgers et par eto'o et qui
démontre qu'il suffit que 20% des
structures ne change pour que tout le
reste suive l'important c'est bon ça et
20% sait pas grand chose c'est
atteignable
et quand on sait que 70 % des gaz à
effet de serre produits par l'homme sont
le fruit d'une centaine d'entreprises
dans le monde et que la moitié des 500
milliards de bouteilles plastiques qui
sont produites chaque année sont le
fruit de moins de dix entreprises
ça donne des perspectives intéressantes
n'en est là l'idée que les entreprises
puissent être le bras armé de la
transition écologique commence à prendre
tout son sens d'autant que une très
grande majorité des chefs d'entreprise
sont prêts à passer
en france c'est même 80 % et 80 %
dixit l'un des mes ppm a gardé au fond
toujours donné ses 180 % c'est touchant
oui 80% c'est énorme
en fait finalement l'enjeu maintenant
c'est le passage à l'acte il faut y
aller maxime et moi et tous les membres
du mouvement qui nous fait que nous
fédérons nous sommes des exemples
concrets de ce passage à l'acte est
ensemble si on s'y met tous on est
capable de déployer ce passage à l'acte
à grande échelle
et voilà nous sommes entrés dans une
nouvelle ère une ère où nos entreprises
vont oeuvrer pour développer des
solutions plus sobre et plus durable une
ère nous devons tous aider les
entreprises à se transformer pour leur
pérennité pour la sauvegarde de notre
planète et notre bien à tous une ère où
nos entreprises vont devenir grâce à
nous tous le bras armé de la transition
écologique
nous sommes la solution vous est la
solution
nos entreprises sont la solution alors
vous aussi faites comme nous entreprenez
pour la planète
merci
[Musique]